us chicks don't feel bad but I say no no
we are supposed to see the best of the
best it's like when you go to the
Olympics you don't go there to see
average people play sports when we go to
Hollywood when we go to when we open a
magazine when I see a model I I want to
be inspired I wanna I wanna be able to
pull off the off the magazine and like
put it on my fridge so I eat less I
really just think that the people in
charge you know they want us stupid that
way we are easy to control and when
women are by ourselves which we really
are
in this economy like we really are more
and more now that we have more single
women than ever more divorced women than
ever and just women as a whole we have
more power than ever